welcome back my next guest led New York
City through its darkest days following
9/11 earning him the nickname America's
mayor eighteen years later the Big Apple
has become the epicenter of the corner
virus epidemic with thousands of new
cases every day is the city prepared for
the virus to peak in the next two weeks
joining me right now is from a New York
City Mayor Rudy Giuliani and mr. mayor
it's always a pleasure to see you thank
you for being here but the pleasure to
be with you Maria you're doing a great
job of covering this terrible crisis
thank you so much I know that you were
in New York this week you toured New
York City Brooklyn other areas what was
your assessment well I spent about three
or four hours in the car yesterday I
drove all through Manhattan and then I
went all the way out to Coney Island
it took some pictures tried to see you
know our people complying the answer is
by and large yes are there some people
that are not that are either not wearing
mass or or too close together yes but
it's a minimum definitely is a minimum
so if you ask me is the city prepared I
would say the people of the city are
emotionally prepared I think the
president the governor and now even the
mayor has has they've all done a good
job of getting the people ready for what
is going to be they say a terrible now
about a week and a half it coincides
interestingly with the Passover with
Good Friday and Easter all very very
solemn religious holidays Passover is
about the angel of death passing over
you praying for it I think people are
sitting at home praying for that so I
think we're prepared are we've prepared
with supplies with the number of
supplies who knows I mean this this
remember before we get too hard on
anybody nobody ever knew that this
existed four months ago right this is uh
this is novell corona virus Novell means
new it's a totally different strain it
acts differently but I think we've made
a lot of progress medically with it we
we have medicines now they can at at
least deal with the symptoms
and some of them become politicized
which is a shame it's really just a
shame and I think with dr. Hahn the
Commissioner of the FDA and he and any
talked about the vaccine talked about
working with hydrochloric when you think
that we should be using hydrochloric win
I think we should let doctors decide
whether we should use hydrochloric win
not the National bureaucracy you know
this this disease can kill you and if
hydrochloric win has side effects
none of which are death by the way then
those side effects I may want to endure
because of the risk of death and it may
be different if I'm 25 or if I'm 75
those choices should be given to doctors
not to the bureaucrats in Washington who
want to go through three blind tests
when we finished the three blind tests
you know most of America could be gone
and they sit there in an ivory tower
whereas the guy sitting at Mount Sinai
in hospital was the person walking in
who's 65 year old 65 years old 104
temperature and I set one there just the
other day first thing they did before
they even talk to him is give him
hydroxychloroquine and it's banned in
New York by the governor why is the
governor banning it everything shows
that it works everything shows that its
side effects don't bother you until you
take it for a month or two for chronic
illness like rheumatoid arthritis or
lupus five administration's of it so far
no side effects and the statistics in
France where they've allowed it whereas
we're exceptionally good yeah there's a
dispute as to whether it treats symptoms
or cures the disease but it works